Kate Middleton continued her chic street  in France the Duchess of Cambridge  turned heads while visiting a  military-led world war one vigil  honoring the 100th anniversary of the  Battle of sue me for the more somber  occasion the Duchess stepped out in this  black white and grey zigzag printed  missoni coat over a black dress she  completed the look with pearl earrings  and a black fascinator hat the stylish  princess joined husband Prince William  and his brother Prince Harry at the  memorial print area later red World War  1 poems to the crowd earlier this month  Middleton appeared just ask classy in  this white lace Dolce and Gabbana dress  a Britain's most valuable race meeting  the Royal Ascot in ascot england